new research shows that being in debt
not only increases anxiety
it also impacts your retirement plans
and marital status too we know those
things but people who have debt
report an increase in stress anxiety and
moodiness the national deep debt relief
noted that this can lead to divorce or
even putting off marriage three in five
Americans have considered putting off
marriage to avoid inheriting their
partner's debt we talked about marriage
and debt a segment ago and 54 believe
having a partner who's in debt is a
major reason to consider divorce
found that people lose over 200 hours of
sleep per year on average over their
debt